toronto surgeon dr chef kachevjie was
finally starting to feel confident his
team was catching up on delayed and
cancelled surgeries then came omicron
our backlog got a lot worse again
because we had to slow down the constant
stopping and starting of procedures as
cova-19 caseloads rise and fall coupled
with burnout of healthcare staff and
limited or space forced long delays for
elective surgeries such as cataracts and
joint operations even transplants and
cancer care were set back close to 600
000 fewer operations were performed
across the country during the first 22
months of the pandemic compared to 2019
but the latest data from the canadian
institute for health information reveals
wait times are starting to improve the
challenge going forward though is we're
still being hospitals are still
being hammered by
covered waves our numbers are changing
behind those numbers are real people
suffering marla marshall received her
liver transplant in december after
waiting 11 months
you're essentially just getting sicker
and sicker
and
[Applause]
waiting on an organ so that
you can
live jessica bailey first spoke to
global last september and is still
waiting on her kidney transplant the
longer i wait the worse my health gets
bailey's sister says her condition has
deteriorated after testing positive for
covent on sunday we are trying to
preserve the status quo we are trying to
do what we used to do
and and think that we can
solve the problem just throwing money at
the decision ottawa promised two billion
dollars to help with the backlogs but
many provinces say it's not enough
public health experts say the solution
has to come at a hospital level
designating some operating rooms for
emergency use and others for elective
only adding more operating hours and
even distributing surgeries
appropriately between doctors kashevji
says no matter the plan time is not on
our side
even if we're doing 110 or 115 percent
of the usual run rate you can see it's
going to take us 10 to 20 months
to catch up on the on the backlog
jamie morocco global news toronto